hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump has been back at the
white house all week after spending last
weekend
hospitalized for the coronavirus but is
his diagnosis hurting his campaign
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on the president's recovery
the vice presidential debate and looks
ahead to next week's supreme court
confirmation hearings
and while we are 25 days out from the
election
over 5 million americans have already
cast
their ballots fox news senior
correspondent eric shawn shares his
insight
on mail-in voting and the legal battles
over it
plus commentary by senior pastor of
first baptist dallas church and fox news
contributor
robert jeffress the fox news rundown is
a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast
player by going to dot
foxnewspodcast.com
i'm janis dean i'm david asman i'm dana
perrino and this is the fox news rundown
friday october 9th 2020 i'm chris foster
fox news sunday host chris wallace says
president trump and others at the white
house being infected with coronavirus
could affect the election
right now uh the coronavirus and covet
and the president's handling of it
is the top issue again and looks like
it's going to be
all the way from now until the election
i'm dave anthony
millions of americans have already made
up their minds
and didn't wait till november to vote we
don't have just
election day it's election month with
early voting and with covert 19
there have been lots of lawsuits and
court cases that have
moved early voting even back earlier
to give more time to give people more
time to vote
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
president trump's been back at the white
house all week after his hospital stay
with coronavirus
no campaign rallies though and no public
appearances except on social media and
tv
telling fox business network i think i'm
better to a point that i feel better
than i did
you know i jokingly said 20 years ago i
feel perfect there's nothing wrong
but he's been losing out on in-person
campaign time three and a half weeks
from election day
the president predicts if he loses look
i stood next to joe and i looked at joe
joe's not lasting two months as
president okay that's my opinion
joe biden's had a consistent lead in
national polls and looks good in some
battleground states president trump won
in 2016
with those polls moving even more his
way over the last two weeks
he leads the president by more than four
points on average in florida now nearly
seven points in pennsylvania
even taking slim leads in georgia iowa
and ohio
biden saying earlier this week during a
speech in gettysburg pennsylvania
i'm running as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work with democrats and republicans
i work as hard for those who don't
support me
as those who do that's the job of a
president
the latest fox news poll has him leading
president trump by 10 points nationally
that's up five from last month
you know i think the president had a
really tough week last week um
by an overwhelming majority in
the polls the president lost the first
debate chris wallace is the host of fox
news sunday the moderator of the first
trump biden debate then he catches
uh the coronavirus uh not only that but
this is
this hot spot this outbreak in and
around the white house
now three dozen people 36 people
uh in the president's broader circle
have the coronavirus
which just raises all kinds of questions
renews questions about how he has dealt
with it
president trump says he feels good um
do you think that his quick recovery
could help him politically
i think uh i don't know i don't think he
gets points for
recovering i'm very happy that he seems
to be recovering and doing so well
we want our president to be healthy we
want our first lady to be healthy but
you know to the degree that there have
been a series of issues
in this campaign that you know have
risen to the top it was the coronavirus
then it was
race and racial justice then it was law
and order then it was the supreme court
you know right now uh the coronavirus
and covet and the president's handling
of it
is the top issue again and looks like
it's going to be all the way from now
till the election and according to all
the polls by a fairly sizable
majority uh people think that the
president it doesn't handle it as well
as joe biden so
you know whether he i mean assuming he
recovers
uh i you know i think this is still a
political negative for him and
particularly
given the fact that it's not just him uh
who's sick or the first lady who's sick
but that there really has been this
this breakout in in the white house
where we're now talking about three
dozen people
well it gets people talking about
coronavirus which isn't what
the trump administration the trump
campaign wanted to talk about now uh any
impressions from the vice presidential
debate it was
certainly more wrote than the one you uh
moderated with the president and joe
biden other than to fly on the vice
president's head for a couple minutes
yeah i mean i it certainly was more of a
debate they they
talked over uh over their time limits
which
is fairly mild that's a you know that's
a traffic ticket compared to the
car crash that i oversaw um
so i you know i thought it was better
the other thing that i guess was
frustrating
was the fact that susan page had some
very good questions
that she asked and then they would
completely ignore them and go off and
answer something else
vice president pence have you had a
conversation
or reached an agreement with president
trump about
safeguards or procedures when it comes
to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
do you think you should you have two
minutes without interruption
well susan uh thank you although i would
like to go back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because the reality is that we're going
to have a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
joe and i are very clear the american
people
are voting right now and it should be
their decision they'd like to know if
you and joe biden are going to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave an
honor to try to answer you
american people deserve a straight
answer yeah let's talk about pack in the
court then
let's talk about this i just want the
record reflection she never answered the
question
you know as a moderator and i certainly
was getting hit last week susan's
getting criticized this week
you you in the end you can't make them
you don't have a you know you don't have
a subpoena you don't have a
a billy club they in the end you have to
depend on the good
faith of the the participants in the
debate that they're gonna
play by the rules that when you ask a
question they're going to answer the
question
and if they're you know duty if they're
just determined not to answer the
questions and play by the rules
there's a limit to what you can do about
the amy coney barrett's uh supreme court
confirmations hearing starts next week
no reason to believe she won't be
confirmed later this month i guess the
process
just speaking politically might be a
reminder of the importance of voting
yeah i and you know it's an interesting
thing
if you again if you believe the polls
most people think
that the winner of the election and the
the winner of the senate after the
election which party holds the senate
that they should determine who uh is on
the court
um and and uh when you look at the
issues whether it's roe v
wade or whether it's obamacare people
don't want to see either of those
overturned so on those
issues uh it seems to favor the
democrats on the other hand
if you know that the court and and and
who's
you know who's who who's being appointed
as judges and
let alone as justices to the supreme
court is so
important is such an article of faith to
republicans and conservatives
that i think that if the president had
said you know what we're just going to
wait for the election and this
or mitch mcconnell said you know what
we're going to wait till after the
election
to vote on this nomination it would have
been such an extreme
turn off to uh to the republican base
that they really had no political choice
uh you know i think they
they if they didn't do it they would
have paid a terrible price even if
on the specific issue the majority of
the country doesn't favor them
right fox news sunday host chris wallace
chris thanks again
you bet thank you
[Music]
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up the election
may be more than three weeks away but a
lot of people
are not waiting we obviously are going
to see more mail voting
than we have in the past florida
governor ron desantis a republican
fortunately in florida we're allowed to
process the ballots as they come in
once the window starts but there's
controversy the state's online voter
registration system
crashed before monday's deadline now
they did let some register after but
there is now a court case to try to
extend it
and there are many more court cases
close to 300 lawsuits have been filed
nationwide over all sorts of things
from the ballots to who's eligible to
get one in the mail to when they have to
be returned
and more than six million people have
already voted
either by mail or at a polling station
open early
four years ago there were only about
seventy 000
votes cast by this time we don't have
just election day it's
election month eric shawn is a fox
senior correspondent and weekend anchor
on the fox news channel
with early voting and with covet 19
there have been lots of lawsuits and
court cases that have uh
moved early voting even back earlier
to give more time uh to give people more
time to vote
and send in their absentee ballot if
they need to be yeah and
i mean there are so many different
issues being litigated
with the ballots themselves and also
with the counting
of the ballots now there are a lot of
states where they can't even
count until election day is that correct
that's correct
under state law uh 15 states
just 15 allow mainland ballots to be
counted before election day
and those deadlines range from one day
before election day to like two weeks
or before a couple of states allow
counting
when they receive the ballots but they
are not allowed to release the results
until
polls close on election day so just
think about it that means you have 35
states
that are are compiling and or getting
all this
mail and all these votes and they got to
put them in the behind lock and key
in the cage and just wait until election
day before they start counting that's
why
you know many say and i think we could
go
days in november before we know exactly
who won
because all the votes won't be in yeah
so what are we going to watch
on election night i mean we're so used
to you know all of a sudden
it's eight o'clock eastern time and
we're calling this state in this state
in this state well i think they would be
able to call some states i think they'll
be able to call a lot of states
those that already have mail-in ballots
in already
so i think you will see a great number
of states called that night but i bet
a dozen plus may not be called because
they're going to have to wait until all
the absentee ballots and all the melon
ballots are returned
and you've got a delays because of these
court cases that stretch on
michigan for example uh has been given
14
days after election day that's two weeks
after election day to uh to
to consider those ballots to be counted
ballots
have to be postmarked by election day
but you're you know i just got something
in the mail that was
today that was mailed two and a half
weeks ago just a regular letter
right so there could be these delays and
we
you know it could stretch for a while we
may be waiting for a couple of big
states
you know a week or even a week longer
but i think we'll get a sense
on election night of where it's going
but if it's a lot of
smaller states with fewer electoral
votes and the
and many big states with big chunks of
electoral votes then
you know get ready to take naps and
sleep and
it's going to be a while dave there's a
lot of different lawsuits in different
states
like i know in new jersey they were
trying to also
stop a mail-in ballot program right i
mean i mean you can go across the
country with this kind of stuff
in new jersey the law has been
that you cannot count the votes until
election day
while the state legislature legislature
went in and they changed
the law and to say that the state
officials can start counting ballots
ten days before the election and that
they can count ballots that are received
two days after the election even ballots
that don't have
a postmark this is all new in new jersey
or the trump campaign opposed the plan
they went into court saying they should
keep what they've had
always which is start counting election
day
count only ballots that arrive by
election day with a postmark
of election day well that's changed a
federal judge
found in favor of the state and uh
allowing them to start early and you're
seeing these type of cases
spread out throughout the country in a
variety in a variety of ways
in south carolina it was the opposite
that happened they have for years have a
witness requirement that
if you have an absentee ballot you need
to get a witness someone else to sign
the back of the ballot
to say yes you are who you are this is a
real person they've had that at state
law in 1953.
state changed it republicans objected
went to the supreme court and the u.s
supreme court ruled in favor of the
republican challenge
uh which is the way the state had been
doing it in the past
now president trump has been claiming
over and over
the election could be rigged with
widespread
fraud they're cheating all over the
place on the ballot so how does that not
a problem
he told fox business on thursday it's a
corrupt system
because they're sending out millions of
ballots now when you send out millions
of ballots when you're the sender you
can send them wherever you want
the president singled out nevada and
he's talked about california before
run by democratic governors and he told
maria
bartoromo two mailmen have been indicted
and
they found trays of ballots in the river
they found uh
eight ballots with my name on military
ballots eight ballots with my name on it
in a waste paper basket
his democratic challenger joe biden said
after their first debate
he didn't think this was going to be if
he lost it wasn't it wouldn't be a
legitimate election already began to
plant in
seeds of doubt in the legitimacy of this
election
i don't know any president's ever done
that before now eric shawn has been
following this closely and he's covered
past elections
what does he think well he's trying to
do this for political reasons the
president david is full of it
in terms of widespread fraud there is no
widespread fraud the election is not
rigged you frankly cannot rig
and tilt and tip and steal
a presidential election the reason for
that is there are 50 different
states 50 different election secretary
of states
and officials that handled the election
and there are 3 000 counties you have
thousands of separate election districts
in order to do this has there been fraud
yes is there fraud
yes there's other mistakes that happened
yes you just mentioned california
they are sending out what's called
universal mail
and that is mailing a ballot to every
registered voter
the democratic argument is that's fine
because voters by registering are saying
we're saying we're ready to vote and you
can get a a ballot
they're mailed out 21 million they are
mailing 21 million of these ballots this
week
they didn't have a problem 2 000 voters
in woodland hills
they got their ballots and guess what
the the presidential race was left off
so critics would say look is there's a
problem but the reality is
that that was found and it's being fixed
and it's being
uh corrected the reality is whether the
ballots are mailed out to
everybody even if you don't ask or only
to
the absentee ballots the way the
president votes and what he says is
acceptable that you want
a ballot the reality is both ballots
have to go through this system
in the same manner you need to have the
election officials will be checking
their personal information the social
security numbers they'll be
they'll do a security matching so there
are the same security standards
of any absentee ballot they will go
through that
whether or not it is a ballot received
from universal mail
or a ballot received uh by asking for it
is it possible and is it is it is there
a potential
that a group or someone uh can like
grab ballots out of a mailbox and just
vote them yes there is
uh is there a possibility that a group
or a bunch of people can grab ballots
for mailboxes and vote enough
to tip a whole state in terms of uh
the election victor uh that is extremely
extremely doubtful it has been done in
the past
the president does talk about ballot
harvesting as you've called it and i
know that republican critics have said
look
there are people who've moved and and
there are people who don't live at the
address anymore
and didn't tell anybody and then ballots
are going to go there
and extra ballots well that's part of
what should be the election security
from the help of america vote act
which is it is up to the uh uh state
election officials to know
if that person is no longer in residence
at the house
uh under the uh hava act they they send
out
if you don't vote they send send a
postcard and if you don't vote in two
separate elections
they drop you from the rolls now people
get all upset over that but that's a
security
measure to make sure that people are who
they
who they say they are ballot harvesting
uh there have been several cases
involved that
those cases basically don't involve
trying to steal an election or stuff a
ballot box they basically
deal with the number of ballots that
someone
can hold uh some states say the limit is
three
in the past there's been a limit of ten
but the states have
have kept a trying to keep a tight
number
on the number of ballots that someone
can't collect california has one of the
worst problems uh um of ballot
harvesters you're not supposed to get
paid for
doing that and this sort of thing is
there potential for fraud is the room
and error
yes but to the president's argument that
they're going to be uh you know
millions of stolen fake
ballots uh to steal the election
uh you know that is quite a uh quite a
a boulder and and challenge and
responsibility for someone or some group
to try to pull off
one of the things also that is being
discussed is with all of these lawsuits
they
may not be resolved at all even close to
being resolved by election day
so what does that do well that's true i
i i think what
if you don't have there have to be
standardized
election rules that the voters should
know about
in each state or in each jurisdiction
but they're always
always dave is a fallback and that's
called a provisional ballot that's
called going before
before a judge it is cumbersome it can
be difficult
uh but it's up to the judicial process
to sort
all this out i have to admit with all
these stories
and you've covered a lot of them and
with all of these issues and legal
issues
it is a little head spinning not knowing
exactly what's going to happen
it really is it's uh and i would be it's
head exploding i mean every we're
getting
five or six court decisions across the
country every day
there are issues being raised here you
know every single day
and and you have to remember and it's
actually a blessing people say well the
russians could steal the election or
some group could try to steal the
election
thankfully unlike other countries we do
not have a
federal nationwide centralized
election system that's a blessing of
what the founding fathers
in their foresight created
thank goodness there are thousands of
separate
election jurisdictions that will give us
dozens and dozens and dozens of court
cases
some of those cases will likely be
conflicting
and they already are conflicting no
matter where you are and each rule is
different in each state and each
each many times even in the same state
because the election the local elections
are run by the county board
counties have different rules and
regulations
that though is turned out to be a
blessing to uh
try and prevent the type of widespread
fraud
and malfeasance that the president has
been a legend
well as the president likes to say we'll
see what happens eric sean
thank you so much for joining us all
right dave thank you
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information on your
time
listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
food network star and restaurateur guy
fieri is giving back to the men
and women fighting the california
wildfires the mayor of flavor town
brought food to more than 2 700
firefighters from the sonoma lake napa
unit of the california department of
forestry and fire protection last
weekend according to the unit's twitter
account
the santa rosa press democrat reports he
served up a salad medley with penne
pasta meatballs and garlic bread for the
firefighters
and even got a crew of chefs and friends
to prepare the food next to the fire
camp at the sonoma county fairground
cal fire's napa unit tweeted their
thanks with a post reading
a million thanks to guy and his talented
team for bringing his delicious delights
to the glass fire base camp
he made a lot of people very happy and
full today
it's not the first time guy has stepped
up to feed californians affected by
wildfires
he did the same thing for responders and
evacuees of the santa rosa fires in 2017
and both the car and campfires in 2018.
he also organized his fellow food
network chefs to thank 3 thousand of the
police officers firefighters emt workers
and doctors who responded in the wake of
the 2017
shooting in las vegas tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind president donald
trump has nominated
appellate judge amy coney barrett to the
supreme court of the united states
over the next several weeks every single
aspect
of judge barrett's life including her
faith will be
questioned ruthlessly and skeptically by
congress
the media and the general public barrett
has been through this before
during judge barrett's confirmation
hearing for her seat on the 7th circuit
in 2017 senator
dianne feinstein tried to raise doubts
about whether barrett's
catholicism would be a hindrance to her
service
in the nation's federal court system
feinstein said ominously
the dogma lives loudly within you
of course what a liberal like feinstein
meant as a damning
accusation was actually what any
committed christian
would count as the highest compliment
the question has never been about
whether judge barrett was qualified
professionally
to serve on the court she clearly is
instead judge barrett represents a
threat because her conservative
catholicism
is embodied in her whole life and it
descends strongly from the progressive
religion
of secularism the dogma lives loudly
within her
because it's undeniable to outsiders
that her life is reflective
of her faith we've come to a strange
place in america
when genuine christianity is a liability
instead of an asset for public office
the moral teachings of christianity
about life
marriage and gender are something that
until very
recently characterized the broad
consensus
of the american public the real problem
is that historic christian claims fly in
the face of the new
secular orthodoxy which has been imposed
by our nation's courts
for over 50 years of course facing
skepticism because of christian faith
isn't too surprising jesus told us
it would happen in john chapter 15 jesus
predicted
if the world hates you know that it has
hated me
before it hated you if you were of the
world
the world would love you as its own but
because you are not of the world
but i chose you out of the world
therefore the world
hates you every person who truly follows
christ will
at some time or another be hated by the
world
when we walk by faith we will inevitably
become
out of step with the culture around us
but we can take heart
even amidst skepticism and persecution
christ is not calling us to go for he
hasn't
already gone himself so let's all
let the dogma live loudly within us
this is robert jeffress
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
it's the perino and stir walt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris steierwell
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes